Well, we've seen that interpreters always work
over Abstract Syntax Trees.
My JavaScript interpreter should be called on our JavaScript parse tree--
our JavaScript Abstract Syntax Tree--
and it's going to arrange to return to us
a string corresponding to what the user was going to print out
as a result of calls to write,
like this string containing (55).
So that result is exactly what we want to display on the Web page.
If this tripped you up because it was almost too simple,
don't worry about it.
Much of the detail in the integration
is in knowing exactly the right way to call the lexar and the parser.
But those aren't endearing concepts
that I really want you to know after that class.
Those are mere implementation details.
Instead, the architecture--
the fact that we can only call interpreters on Abstract Syntax Trees
and that we've decided to pass string results back
and then display them, using our graphics library--
that's important; that's a design decision.
This--this is a historical accident.
That's why I gave all of you these, for free,
and asked you to tell me about these conceptual bits.